[Musique]
puis quelques temps je me suis rendu
compte que en règle générale les mecs
savent pas trop faire une cravate
ça c'est valable pour beaucoup beaucoup
de potes comme en ce moment on a plein
de potes qui se marient et que ont fait
la fête à tout va je me rends vraiment
compte que c'est pas ça toujours des
potes avec des noeuds de cravate un peu
douteux puis de toute façon ça les fait
chier et au bout de quelques minutes ils
finissent par les dégager tout
simplement plus de cravates et c'est
bien dommage parce qu'un bon oeil
cravate c'est quand même super élégant
alors je vais te montrer de façon hyper
simple comment faire un noeud cravate
j'ai donné trois méthodes hyper facile
tu me diras ce que tu en penses
karine moi je choisir ma cravate
ceinture marron pantalon bleu chemise
bleue cravate bleu le jaune unique et un
petit peu too much mais que j'aime
beaucoup les petits coeurs petit christ
sur la croix il ya quelques années est
une autre que j'aime bien aussi
cette italienne gino rossini on va
mettre les lacroix pour la vidéo elle
sera un peu plus tonique
ça devrait aller mais avant de faire un
noeud de cravate tu commence toujours
par l'ontt et on colle quand même plus
simple alors bon moi j'ai un grand coup
si charles là je suis mort donc je
laisse couverte c'est pas grave
petit bout hauteur du nombril et il faut
que ton gros bout arrive au niveau de la
ceinture
si le gros bout il arrive tout en bas ça
indique le terrain de jeu s'il arrive en
haut ça veut dire que t'es trop gros et
trop gros tu va regarder cette vidéo
ok tu aimais bien à hauteur du nombril
l'or va commencer par le simple alors le
principe c'est que tu prends toujours
d'un gros bout et c'est lui qui va faire
les tours et qui va se balader
c'est lui qui tricotent lui la petit
bouge pas tu pars du gros tu passes
devant tu fais un petit haut tu passes
derrière tu repasse devant
tu vois et ensuite tu passes derrière
entre les deux futurs sera hyper facile
et ensuite tu prends note a fait devant
là tu vois ici là là et tu attends tu
plonges dans puis comme disent les vieux
voilà ça c'est un de simple tu le
remonte en tirant sur la languette du
petit tu positionne normalement si tu as
fait le boulot à peu près correctement
tchèque
tu arrives au niveau de la ceinture pour
après tout peut donner un peu de forme
tu te tires sur le petit ça te fait
remonter dont on colle je redescends le
col tu sers un peu en eau était beau
comme un camion le double c'est pas plus
compliqué en réalité le double tu fais
juste autour de plus ce que ça va faire
c'est que ça va épaissir un petit peu et
ça te fera en aucun peu plus gros mais
c'est exactement le même principe le
petit au niveau du nombril tu prends en
gros tu passes devant par derrière et là
au lieu de remonter et de plonger à turf
encore ok refait un tour et là tu sais
pas dedans et tu sais comme pour l'autre
tu plonges dedans tu vois ça te fait un
noeud qui est quand même un peu plus
haut
je lui donne un peu de forme avec ta
main pierre c'est pas mon préféré
moi ce que je préfère c'est le windsor
plus de classe et une plus belle forme
le windsor or c'est pas bien compliqué
mais par contre celle là il faut la
rentrée plus haut à peu près par la
troisième quatrième bouton tu prends un
gros bout il passe devant
ensuite tu sais pas c'est dedans ok je
vais y arriver
voilà tu passe dedans une fois que tu es
pas cette danse tu passe sur la droite
tu contourne la petite tactique est là
tu qu'on tourne et tu reviens dedans en
gros tu as fait tout une fact a fait le
tour ce que tu fais c'est que par ce
côté là on passe par la droite
as tu passes devant tu fais le tour tu
ressors d'arrière gauche et et là c'est
le même système de toute façon tu
plonges dedans voilà quand tu veux le
serrer tourner tu tires sur le gros
quand tu veux le descendre tu tires sur
le petit et si tu regarde en bas je suis
toujours au niveau de ma ceinture c'est
vachement plus jolie parce que c'est
plus gros en réalité comme de 3 noeuds
le noeud simple le double et le windsor
tu gardes ces bases là après l'heure
n'existe plein d'autres franchement
c'est pas la peine de te casser ça
dépend de ta cravate
ça dépend de la texture c'est un truc
est très fin
enfin si et ça ça dépend comment tu
t'habilles sa dépendent pas mal de
choses moi ce que je te conseille ses
parts être des windsor ce surplus
élégant d'avoir en eux qui est un peu
plus gros après tu le boss tu vois tu le
modèle à la main parfait tenter ce que
tu veux sur le début de soirée tu fais
un truc un peu plus strictes qui va
comment dieu qu'ils soient et sur la fin
de soirée battu des temps un petit peu
un peu plus à la cool on va pas se la
mettre sur le front on n'est pas chez
patrick sébastien
si tu me suis par contre voilà tu peux
tu peux voir différentes variantes et
surtout c'est très beau donc maintenant
tu as plus aucune excuse si tu ne sais
pas faire notre cravate c'est vraiment
timé aucune volonté si ça te convient si
ces quelques conseils ont été
intéressants pour toi d'un temps jairo
booth n'hésite pas à ta bonne et à la
chaîne n'oublie pas mon lapin je
penserai toi ici tu as des idées s'il ya
des sujets qui intéressent des choses
sur lesquelles tu sèches et tâtonne un
petit coup de main tu me lis un
commentaire où tu m'envoies un message
dans la rubrique à propos il ya mon
email n'hésite pas tu m'écris je
t'embrasse lapin à bientôt